[Musique]
si le québec devenait s'ouvrait demain
matin il serait le pays le plus riche de
l'histoire occidentale à avoir réalisé
son indépendance c'est ce qu'affirme
l'ancien ministre des finances nicolas
marceau dans un ouvrage qui paraît cette
semaine une fois le québec souverain
chez vlb éditeur nicolas marceau est
professeur titulaire du département au
département des sciences économiques de
l'uqam et il est avec nous ce soir
bonsoir nicolas marceau merci de me
savoir plaisir de vous de vous avoir
votre livre
sort un moment quand même bien précis de
notre histoire parce qu'on est à l'aube
d'une élection au québec pourquoi
maintenant sortir un livre sur la
souveraineté du québec bah écoutez le
d'une part du feu qui vient de ce que ça
prend du temps j'ai commencé à deux ans
ou au début de la pandémie puis bon
arriver à un résultat satisfaisant ça a
pris deux ans et aussi demain c'est le
100e anniversaire de naissance de
monsieur rené lévesque c'est vrai en
deuxième demie mais en fait c'est
vraiment vous j'aurais voulu que lui
paraissent avant ce livre je crois bien
honnête mais ça et c'est un livre qui
est un appel je dirais aux
rassemblements des souverainistes à
l'humain de gauche et de droite
exact et autour d'un projet qui ne
serait pas un projet de société qui
serait simplement un projet
d'indépendance expliquez nous pourquoi
vous faites cet appel
vient le constat que je fais c'est que
les québécois se sont le québec s'est
développé les québécois se sont enrichis
bon juste traditionnellement le
mouvement souverainiste de parler
essentiellement aux gens de gauche ou
sociaux-démocrates où vous inquiétez
plus à gauche que ça mais moi je pense
que les québécois ont bougé ont changé à
travers le temps et que le projet de
souveraineté ne s'adresse pas qu'à la
gauche adresse aussi à la droite et je
pense que si on veut réussir à réunir
une quantité suffisante de québécois
pour atteindre le but de souveraineté il
faut rassembler ces québécois qui
aujourd'hui ont une pluralité de vision
sur les enjeux politiques donc le projet
d'indépendance qui était porté davantage
vers le centre gauche ni plus
nécessairement un projet de société de
centre gauche dit non par contre la
dépendance à ouvre la possibilité
d'avoir une société plus égalitaire mais
aussi plus riche plus certes il ya un
ensemble de possibilités qui est plus
large avec la souveraineté pourquoi
parce que premièrement c'est la fin du
gaspillage de ressources qui décolle de
la double micro crédit dans laquelle on
est présentement dans le régime fédéral
en plus de cela les choix faits dans un
québec souverain vont être adaptés aux
circonstances des québécois ou
circonstances du québec alors
qu'aujourd'hui on a on doit accepter les
compromis puisque les décisions sont
prises ottawa en fonction de l'ensemble
du canada puis le canadien moyen est
différent du québécois moyen donc on
aurait un ensemble des possibles plus
large dans un québec souverain qui
reviendrait à un québec plus riche débat
possible ce que je dis c'est que dans un
québec souverain des québécois
choisiront bien là dit la direction dans
laquelle ils veulent aller mais s'ils
veulent aller vers plus de richesse plus
d'enrichissement ou plus d'équité ou
plus de danse de protection
d'environnement ils pourront faire ce
choix là le point c'est qu' environ plus
de possibilités que dans le québec
province mais pourquoi le québec serait
plus prospère avec un pib par habitant
qui seraient plus élevés pourquoi vous
vous aller jusqu'à dire que sur le plan
économique parce que québec serait plus
positif
parce que présentement encore une fois
il ya des décisions qui sont prises
par le gouvernement fédéral à la vente à
jouant avec pour objectif si vous voulez
de répondre aux problèmes canadien or le
canada le québec c'est deux choses
distinctes visionner un exemple prenons
simplement le code des hydrocarbures
au canada on prend soin de ne pas
fermer les au carbure de l'ouest moi je
pense que c'est une erreur mais bon quoi
qu'il en soit tenu compte seulement
quand même au québec que nous consommons
mais nous on a tout ce qu'il faut pour
faire une transition vers des énergies
propres on doit développer encore plus
les énergies propres de l'appui fédéral
aux hydrocarbures nous empêche de
développer mieux nous et non j'ai pas
alors mais ce que je sais ça c'est un
exemple parmi plusieurs il ya plein dans
tous les autres sur tous les sujets vous
allez trouver des décisions prises par
ottawa qui sont prises en fonction du
canadien moyen du canada de manière
légitime évidemment mais ça ne
correspond pas est ce que le québec aux
besoins comment remplacent les 13,14
milliards de péréquation
sur la question des finances publiques
il faut regarder lens angles des
éléments l'ensemble des éléments la
péréquation les transferts fédéraux qui
sont considérables il faut il faut il
faut le dire ce n'est qu'un des éléments
par ailleurs dans un québec indépendant
on va rapatrier au québec l'ensemble des
dépenses qui sont présentement effectués
par ottawa au québec donc on va devoir
effectuer ces dépenses là on veut
rapatrier les revenus aussi qui sont
présentement récoltés par ottawa au
québec désormais vont être récoltées par
le québec on veut aussi puis gelé déjà
mentionné épargner beaucoup de
ressources qui découle de la double
bureaucratie des chevauchements entre
les deux autres des niveaux de
gouvernement et quand on fait l'examen
de l'ensemble de ses composantes leur
positionnement de la péréquation c'est
un élément important mais c'est un
élément parmi plusieurs enfin quel 20,7
milliards de dollars de transferts
fédéraux au québec dont 13 14 millions
c'est ça aussi mais il ya aussi des
dépenses effectuées par le fédéral des
revenus qui sont récoltées par le
fédéral une double d'euros créé sea dont
on se débarrasserait quand on fait le
compte de l'ensemble des éléments on
arrive à la conclusion que les finances
publiques du québec serait temps santé
ok on arrive à la conclusion que le
québec serait en mesure d'offrir les
mêmes services qu'ottawa qui sont
offertes aujourd'hui par ottawa et ce à
cette conclusion là on y est arrivé en
92 avec le comsup énergie campo ont été
rouverts encore en 2005 avec une étude
qui avaient été faites par le parti
québécois en 2016 avec une étude qui a
été faite par maxime duchesne donc et
d'autres études concluront la même chose
alors il ya beaucoup de choses dans
votre livre un élément sur lequel je
vous entends depuis malheureusement ce
sera le temps que nous avons c'est quand
même en 1995 le jacques parizeau voulait
garder le dollar qui avait si vous vous
dites non on devrait pas faire ça vous
êtes on devrait avoir un dollar
québécois veut ancrer au dollar
américain à long terme là mêmes fixe
pendant cinq ans un taux fixe à 5 ans
pourquoi deux choses de raison en fait
on s'est rendu compte dans l'est depuis
le référendum de 95 qu'il y avait des
problèmes avec le fait d'avoir de
dollars canadiens je donne un exemple
pendant les années 2000 vous vous
rappellerez que le dollar canadien a
augmenté beaucoup en raison de la hausse
du prix du pétrole sao rendu les
produits manufacturiers québécois moins
compétitif sur les marchés étrangers
puis là le résultat des courses a été
que nous secteur manufacturier a décliné
les exportations québécoises ont décliné
bref on a mangé une volée dans le
secteur manufacturier des années 2000
pourquoi parce que la politique
monétaire canadienne n'était pas adapté
aux circonstances de l'économie
québécoise
alors 7,7 le fait que la politique
monétaire canadienne qui repose donc sur
le dollar canadien soit mal adapté à
notre situation moi je pense que c'est
coûteux et que avec un monet une devise
québécoise on serait capable d'avoir une
politique monétaire mieux adapté à nos
circonstances c'est la première raison
la deuxième raison c'est que on s'est
rendu compte aussi depuis les années 90
que les crises financières étaient plus
fréquentes à travers le globe bienvenue
aux états unis en europe et au lieu
partout et quand il ya une crise
financière ça prend un prêteur de
dernier recours pour venir à la
rescousse de nos institutions
financières s'il ya des problèmes cette
ce prêteur de dernier recours si la
banque centrale est donc pour un québec
indépendant dans un monde où il ya des
crises financières il serait avantageux
d'avoir une banque centrale pour agir
comme prêteur de dernier recours vous
appeler au rassemblement vous appeler au
rassemblement à l'intérieur ou à
l'extérieur du parti québécois ma
dernière question est-ce que vous
appuyez encore le parti québécois
nicolas marceau oui absolument non
seulement aucun doute associé à ce sujet
j'appuie deux parties avec quoi je vote
est parti québécois la prochaine liste
d'accords alors merci merci et puis je
rappelle ce livre une fois le québec
souverain chez vlb éditeur merci
beaucoup une colère saison en beauté
avec nous ce soir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne i cirdi
oh